When trying to minimize a sum-of-products
expression using the reduction identity, our
goal is to find two product terms that can
be written as one smaller product term, eliminating
the "don't-care" variable.
This is easy to do when two the product terms
come from adjacent rows in the truth table.
For example, look at the bottom two rows in
this truth table.
Since the Y output is 1 in both cases, both
rows will be represented in the sum-of-products
expression for this function.
It's easy to spot the don't care variable:
when C and B are both 1, the value of A isn't
needed to determine the value of Y.
Thus, the last two rows of the truth table
can be represented by the single product term
(B AND C).
Finding these opportunities would be easier
if we reorganized the truth table so that
the appropriate product terms were on adjacent
rows.
That's what we've done in the Karnaugh map,
K-map for short, shown on the right.
The K-map organizes the truth table as a two-dimensional
table with its rows and columns labeled with
the possible values for the inputs.
In this K-map, the first row contains entries
for when C is 0 and the second row contains
entries for when C is 1.
Similarly, the first column contains entries
for when A is 0 and B is 0.
And so on.
The entries in the K-map are exactly the same
as the entries in the truth table, they're
just formatted differently.
Note that the columns have been listed in
a special sequence that's different from the
usual binary counting sequence.
In this sequence, called a Gray Code, adjacent
labels differ in exactly one of their bits.
In other words, for any two adjacent columns,
either the value of the A label changed, or
the value of the B label changed.
In this sense, the leftmost and rightmost
columns are also adjacent.
We write the table as a two-dimensional matrix,
but you should think of it as cylinder with
its left and right edges touching.
If it helps you visualize which entries are
adjacent, the edges of the cube shows which
3-bit input values differ by only one bit.
As shown by the red arrows, if two entries
are adjacent in the cube, they are also adjacent
in the table.
It's easy to extend the K-map notation to
truth tables for functions with 4 inputs,
as shown here.
We've used a Gray code sequencing for the
rows as well as the columns.
As before, the leftmost and rightmost columns
are adjacent, as are the top and bottom rows.
Again, as we move to an adjacent column or
an adjacent row, only one of the four input
labels will have changed.
To build a K-map for functions of 6 variables
we'd need a 4x4x4 matrix of values.
That's hard to draw on the 2D page and it
would be a challenge to tell which cells in
the 3D matrix were adjacent.
For more than 6 variables we'd need additional
dimensions.
Something we can handle with computers, but
hard for those of us who live in only a three-dimensional
space!
As a practical matter, K-maps work well for
up to 4 variables, and we'll stick with that.
But keep in mind that you can generalize the
K-map technique to higher dimensions.
So why talk about K-maps?
Because patterns of adjacent K-map entries
that contain 1's will reveal opportunities
for using simpler product terms in our sum-of-products
expression.
Let's introduce the notion of an implicant,
a fancy name for a rectangular region of the
K-map where the entries are all 1's.
Remember when an entry is a 1, we'll want
the sum-of-products expression to evaluate
to TRUE for that particular combination of
input values.
We require the width and length of the implicant
to be a power of 2, i.e., the region should
have 1, 2, or 4 rows, and 1, 2, or 4 columns.
It's okay for implicants to overlap.
We say that an implicant is a prime implicant
if it is not completely contained in any other
implicant.
Each product term in our final minimized sum-of-products
expression will be related to some prime implicant
in the K-map.
Let's see how these rules work in practice
using these two example K-maps.
As we identify prime implicants, we'll circle
them in red.
Starting with the K-map on the left, the first
implicant contains the singleton 1-cell that's
not adjacent to any other cell containing
1's.
The second prime implicant is the pair of
adjacent 1's in the upper right hand corner
of the K-map.
This implicant is has one row and two columns,
meeting our constraints on an implicant's
dimensions.
Finding the prime implicants in the right-hand
K-map is a bit trickier.
Recalling that the left and right columns
are adjacent, we can spot a 2x2 prime implicant.
Note that this prime implicant contains many
smaller 1x2, 2x1 and 1x1 implicants, but none
of those would be prime implicants since they
are completely contained in the 2x2 implicant.
It's tempting draw a 1x1 implicant around
the remaining 1, but actually we want to find
the largest implicant that contains this particular
cell.
In this case, that's the 1x2 prime implicant
shown here.
Why do we want to find the largest possible
prime implicants?
We'll answer that question in a minute…
Each implicant can be uniquely identified
by a product term, a Boolean expression that
evaluates to TRUE for every cell contained
within the implicant and FALSE for all other
cells.
Just as we did for the truth table rows at
the beginning of this chapter, we can use
the row and column labels to help us build
the correct product term.
The first implicant we circled corresponds
to the product term (not A) AND (not B)
AND C, an expression that evaluates to TRUE
when A is 0, B is 0, and C is 1.
How about the 1x2 implicant in the upper-right
hand corner?
We don't want to include the input variables
that change as we move around in the implicant.
In this case the two input values that remain
constant are C (which has the value 0) and
A (which has the value 1), so the corresponding
product term is A AND (not C).
Here are the two product terms for the two
prime implicants in the right-hand K-map.
Notice that the larger the prime implicant,
the smaller the product term!
That makes sense: as we move around inside
a large implicant, the number of inputs that
remain constant across the entire implicant
is smaller.
Now we see why we want to find the largest
possible prime implicants: they give us the
smallest product terms!
Let's try another example.
Remember that we're looking for the largest
possible prime implicants.
A good way to proceed is to find some un-circled
1, and then identify the largest implicant
we can find that incorporates that cell.
There's a 2x4 implicant that covers the middle
two rows of the table.
Looking at the 1's in the top row, we can
identify two 2x2 implicants that include those
cells.
There's a 4x1 implicant that covers the right
column, leaving the lonely 1 in the lower
left-hand corner of the table.
Looking for adjacent 1's and remembering the
table is cyclic, we can find a 2x2 implicant
that incorporates this last un-circled 1.
Notice that we're always looking for the largest
possible implicant, subject to constraint
that each dimension has to be either 1, 2
or 4.
It's these largest implicants that will turn
out to be prime implicants.
Now that we've identified the prime implicants,
we're ready to build the minimal sum-of-products
expression.
Here are two example K-maps where we've shown
only the prime implicants needed to cover
all the 1's in the map.
This means, for example, that in the 4-variable
map, we didn't include the 4x1 implicant covering
the right column.
That implicant was a prime implicant since
it wasn't completely contained by any other
implicant, but it wasn't needed to provide
a cover for all the ones in the table.
Looking at the top table, we'll assemble the
minimal sum-of-products expression by including
the product terms for each of the shown implicants.
The top implicant has the product term A AND
(not C), and the bottom implicant has the
product term (B AND C).
And we're done!
Why is the resulting equation minimal?
If there was some further reduction that could
be applied, to produce a yet smaller product
term, that would mean there was a larger prime
implicant that could have been circled in
the K-map.
Looking the bottom table, we can assemble
the sum-of-products expression term-by-term.
There were 4 prime implicants, so there are
4 product terms in the expression.
And we're done.
Finding prime implicants in a K-map is faster
and less error-prone that fooling around with
Boolean algebra identities.
Note that the minimal sum-of-products expression
isn't necessarily unique.
If we had used a different mix of the prime
implicants when building our cover, we would
have come up with different sum-of-products
expression.
Of course, the two expressions are equivalent
in the sense that they produce the same value
of Y for any particular combination of input
values - they were built from the same truth
table after all.
And the two expressions will have the same
number of operations.
So when you need to come with up a minimal
sum-of-products expression for functions of
up to 4 variables, K-maps are the way to go!
We can also use K-maps to help us remove glitches
from output signals.
Earlier in the chapter we saw this circuit
and observed that when A was 1 and B was 1,
then a 1-to-0 transition on C might produce
a glitch on the Y output as the bottom product
term turned off and the top product term turned
on.
That particular situation is shown by the
yellow arrow on the K-map, where we're transitioning
from the cell on the bottom row of the 1-1
column to the cell on the top row.
It's easy to see that we're leaving one implicant
and moving to another.
It's the gap between the two implicants that
leads to the potential glitch on Y.
It turns out there's a prime implicant that
covers the cells involved in this transition
- shown here with a dotted red outline.
We didn't include it when building the original
sum-of-products implementation since the other
two product terms provided the necessary functionality.
But if we do include that implicant as a third
product term in the sum-of products, no glitch
can occur on the Y output.
To make an implementation lenient, simply
include all the prime implicants in the sum-of-products
expression.
That will bridge the gaps between product
terms that lead to potential output glitches.